ALEX PACHIKOV: Hi.
I'm Alex Pachikov from Evernote,
and I'm the VP for
partnerships.
HEMANT GARG: Hi.
I'm Hemant Garg.
I'm Android tech lead
at Evernote.
TY SMITH: Hi.
I'm Ty Smith, and I'm a senior
Android engineer at Evernote.
ALEX PACHIKOV: We launched
Evernote in
the summer of 2008.
We basically figured that
nobody's quite happy with
their actual brains and they
really needed something to
help them remember everything
that they see.
So I wanted to build Evernote to
be a product, an app, and a
service that will help you
capture anything that's
important to you, anywhere
you are, and always
help you find it.
So whenever you wake up, the
first device you can reach
with your hand, whether it's a
phone or a tablet, you should
be able to just get
to your important
information right away.
We want you to use Evernote your
whole life, so we're not
in a rush to monetize
the application.
We want people to use it for
free for as long as they want.
And once you use it and once
you put a lot of stuff into
it, you will see some of the
power features that are our
premium features that
we charge for.
Let me give you an example.
Say you've been using Evernote
to store a bunch of documents.
One of the premium
features that we
have is document search.
Document search lets us index
all of the contents of all of
the office documents you have
in Evernote and make them
searchable.
So when I go to search, I will
see a little pop up that says,
did you know this is
a premium feature?
And I can buy it right there,
directly with an in-app
subscription.
TY SMITH: Because Evernote is
a long-term product for our
users, we felt like the
subscription model made the
most sense.
And when the Billing APIs came
out for the different app
stores, we took advantage of
those as soon as we could.
At first we were only able to
take advantage of monthly
in-app billing.
Users would have to resubscribe
every month, and
this had a fairly high churn
rate we saw near 70%.
With the rise of subscription
models in the In-App Paying
APIs, we've seen that reduced
down to near 30% on Android,
which has been fantastic.
ALEX PACHIKOV: Today, Evernote
has about 50 million users.
About 70% of our users come from
mobile first, but most
people use Evernote on
multiple devices--
phones, tablets, PCs.
And we really see that Evernote
is most useful to
people when you use it across
different devices, because you
never know which device you're
going to have close to you.
When we saw the rise of tablets,
we really took it
very seriously.
We knew that Evernote had a
huge opportunity to be an
important native
app on tablets.
And we built it early on as best
as we can, and we put as
much work into the UI of the
tablets as we did into the
phones and our PC versions.
And today we see ourselves as
one of the top productivity
apps on every tablet that there
is-- specifically on the
Nexus 7, which is our second
most popular device.
TY SMITH: We've seen a lot of
tablet growth recently.
So I wanted to walk you through
some of our best
practices that we've discovered
on tablet, and how
we gave the users a
great experience.
HEMANT GARG: We wanted to give
better user experience to our
tablet users, so we thought
tablet users have to be more
engaging and more power users.
So we gave them double panels,
and they can do more stuff at
the same time.
We gave them a quick and easy
way to access their notebooks,
their tags, places.
And at the same time, they can
see what's happening with
their account and
all their notes.
TY SMITH: Our anticipation's
turned out to be correct.
The average session length for a
tablet user is almost double
that of the phone user.
We also anticipated that on
tablet with the larger screen
real estate that we'd
see a lot more
users creating content.
ALEX PACHIKOV: Android is
the fastest growing
platform for Evernote.
So we're really excited about
what's coming up in the
future, and we're working
on lots of cool stuff.
Thank you for watching.
HEMANT GARG: Thank you.
TY SMITH: Thank you.